here now with more are the Senators they
are behind the key report detailing
Hunter's Shady finances Wisconsin
Senator Ron Johnson along with Iowa
Senator Chuck Grassley a gentlemen great
to see you both I'll start with you
Senator Johnson if you can explain you
know what we now know is there anything
in my monologue that you heard that is
not true and what else are you learning
as you dig deeper into your
investigation
no Sean you laid it all out and of
course we've known this those of us that
had inquiry Minds we've known this for
you know close to two years now it was
obvious Hunter's laptop was authentic as
soon as he started seeing the
information from it but the media has
been complicit here's a few more details
100 by knew exactly who he was dealing
with you know he called Patrick ho the
Spy chief of China
he knew that uh Devin Archer was
involved in a you know he was eventually
we proved that he was involved in a
fraud against Indian tribes he was
convicted of that Devin Archer met with
Joe Biden in the White House in April
2014 right around the exact same time
within a couple days we went Devin
Archer became a board member a barisma a
few weeks later Hunter Biden became a
board member so this is an enormous
tangled web of you know a vast web of
the financial foreign entanglements and
we've known this all along and as Tony
boblinski said uh Joe Biden is
compromised I I think it's pretty
obvious he has to be cancels Nordstrom
II pipeline he cancels the China
initiative which is the doj
investigations into universities of uh
Chinese stealing our intellectual
property so no this is incredibly dirty
but the mainstream media has been
complicit they've been covering it up
and what the Washington Post learned
from its next Nixon coverage is when you
when you've been caught covering things
up you do a modified limited hangout
that's exactly what the Washington Post
did they're not revealing all the
information this is minimal information
for the American public they're just
covering their you know what
you know Senator Grassley in your report
in November 2020 which we covered
extensively you pointed out over the
course of your investigation into how
Hunter Biden would use his father's
position and name to enrich himself and
his father uh and the fact that in these
emails from this laptop we now can
confirm that Joe Biden benefited
financially from it also Joe Biden lied
to the American people when he said he
never had discussions with Hunter about
his foreign business dealings uh you
tell me Senator this is not our first
rodeo uh in on issues like this that
sounds like pay-to-play corruption to me
well we have bank records that back up
everything that is in the laptop and
they very clearly show that there was
these uh bank records that tie a hunter
Biden directly with people in China
business people in China that are
directly connected with the Chinese
Communist party and the government and
to some extent maybe the military and
the intelligence service so there's no
doubt about it but the really sad thing
is the media should have been doing
their job in August of 2019 when I
started this investigation and instead
what they were doing was peddling the
information that the Democrats were
putting out is that we were peddling Uh
Russian disinformation and now we know
it's the Democrats and the media that
was backing up were the ones peddling
the Russian disinformation and could you
imagine Senator John constant of the
last name of Hunter happened to be Trump
in your report as you have gone forward
and what you said earlier this week is
that you discovered you and Senator
Grassley that money from the cefc which
is effectively an arm of the Chinese
government was went directly to Hunter
Biden now there's a shopping spree
involved there's five million dollars
involved uh a billion five deal with the
Bank of China I'm not sure why they
wouldn't go to Goldman Sachs or or
Deutsche Bank or JP Morgan Chase and a
real company because I don't see any
experience he had but these have ties
directly to the Communist Chinese
government does it not and Military
yeah absolutely and remember XI Jing
Ming the chairman of the cefc he just
went missing you know cefc it's a
multi-billion dollar oil and gas company
just kind of goes poof that that doesn't
happen with the legitimate company that
that's a company that's controlled by
the the Communist Chinese party and
let's face it just you know 5 million a
million three and a half million four
million dollars from Greece we're up
already over 13 million dollars for what
what what qualified Hunter Biden from
getting all that money for Biden Inc his
name he was influence influence peddling
this is the sleaziest thing that I've
seen certainly in politics and you know
I want to really thank Senator Grassley
for his tenaciousness in helping me
investigate this we've been pretty good
team uh by the way Sean we both have
tough re-elections we need a lot of help
from your audience I'm Ron Johnson
senate.com Chuck is grassleyworks.com
and he does work hard if you want to get
the ex all this stuff exposed we need
some help Senator Grassley this is the
main question Joe Biden lied when he
said he had no knowledge of his son's
foreign business dealings now we know
that's a lie now the question is uh as
it relates to Russia Kazakhstan Ukraine
and China uh is it possible we have a
president of the United States that is
compromised that they have personal
information potentially blackmail
information about Hunter Biden former
crack addict a guy that frequented
prostitutes uh and that might compromise
his ability to deal with these countries
is that a fair question Senator it is a
fair question and at this point it's a
question with me but every American
ought to keep it back as his mind as as
particularly as our government is
dealing with the Chinese government our
number one competitor uh in the world
and a number two economy in the world
and I think it's legitimate to raise
that question I wish I could say
absolutely absolutely yes but for
somebody to say that over the years that
eight years of being vice president and
also then being out of office but still
having the Biden name and The Prestige
of that that uh that you never talk this
with your family that's just like my son
and I are in farming we talk about
farming all the time
exactly same question Senator Johnson
um is it now we learned that Libya had a
dossier and they knew all about Hunter
Biden's issues let's put I'm being kind
uh isn't it likely the Communist Chinese
and the Russians and the ukrainians and
all these other countries have a dossier
of dirt on Joe Hunter Biden and the rest
of the family Syndicate because I would
say that puts them in a position of
potential blackmail is that right
yeah Sean we may not know all the
details but I'll tell you who does
Russian intelligence Chinese
intelligence Iranian intelligence North
Korean intelligence you know my guess
there are elements within our
intelligence Department our intelligence
community that knows well they're just
not going to tell us they're not going
to tell the American public because
there's corruption in the Deep State
Chuck and I we we've asked for
information from Gina haspel she
wouldn't even return our phone call to
tell us why she wouldn't respond to our
legitimate oversight request so it's a
very deep State it's pervasive it's com
it's filled with liberal leftists and
that's one of our big problems in this
country today well if that's true then
that means we have as a country a
potentially a compromised president
potentially uh his family subject to
Blackmail of some kind or they have some
leverage that they hold over them
Senator Johnson Senator Grassley thank
you both for being courageous and
supporting both of you and your
campaigns hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else